une première voile alors je vais vous
présenter les deux dernières filles ça
c'est la petite la key buy cg sainte
c'est un king cher et puis elle a ses
mirabel tâches entre nos alors mirabel
gelée elle a un an et demi et sa soeur
là elle a presque deux ans mirabel c'est
une petite canadienne
je suis parrain du de l'aéroport de
montréal qui s'appelle mirabel et pour
me remercier des canadiens m'ont fait
cadeau de cette petite fille dayan qui
s'appelle comme l'aéroport mirabel
c'est très très intelligent très fidèle
très affectueux quand comme je viens pas
très souvent ce moment la campagne alors
comme suis absenté longtemps mais quand
je viens fait la fête pendant deux jours
et des malades est très émotive très
sensible quant à cette petite teigne là
est la tranquille car c'est la
télévision alors c'est le petit là elle
est très nerveuse est très très très
susceptibles êtes une vraie actrice
d'été genthod si elles s'entendent bien
elles ont été levées ensemble elles se
mordent petit peu de temps en temps
comme des frères et soeurs mais celle là
elle est très aimée comme voyez toujours
des coups ça elles aiment bien inventer
sur le libye et qu'elle n'avait pas
d'autorisation
elle se met vite sous les couvertures
très frileuse un bel orage
les orages
alors date et wanda sa mère est prévenue
pas connu j'ai tourné de bossert je me
suis cassé de werther et j'ai été dans
le plâtre pendant six mois j'ai été
opérée gta gars tout ça alors le médecin
le professeur le père lord qui m'a opéré
qui m'a d'ailleurs sauvé la vie m'avait
demandé de ne pas bouger pendant six
mois dans le plat donc j'étais couché à
une coquille comme ça sans bouger et
j'habitais saint cloud dans
l'appartement et un jour une dame une
admiratrice une dame qui m'aimait bien
qu'ils trouvaient que j'étais pas tant
comme acteur et tout ça est arrivé avec
un petit panier et une petit teckel
naine qui s'appelait isis la déesse de
la médecine et elle avait six mois avec
une grosse un gros d'un gros ruban coûts
et une petite lettre en disant bonjour
c'est moi isis voilà ce que je mange la
ce que je bois je serai un peu des
compagnes je reste avec vous
effectivement il y est resté avec moi
d'ailleurs elle est morte très très
âgées elle est morte avait 16 ans et
elle m'a fait des enfants
alors elle elle est une des phillies
il ya aussi notre garçon que j'ai donné
à jeanne moreau et et puis un autre que
j'ai donné à une amie voilà elle a fait
trois enfants alors j'en ai que j'en ai
gardé je m'égare d une mois celle là il
devrait bien qu'elle me pas est petit
mais elle est tellement bizarre elle
aime pas tellement et chiant c'est un
bon gars doivent avoir une fiancée l'a
bien
ma fille a ressassé nobody c'est le fox
a pas la grille donc vous dit elle m'a
été donné pendant j'étais en tournée
avec la plus à l'oreille et elle m'a été
donné par des amis qui me suis qui aux
élevages
alors j'ai eu toute petite toute petite
elle a continué la tournée avec moi mais
le drame de la mode i have a drame dans
sa vie c'est qu'elle ne supporte deux
pas des autres chiens ni les autres les
litiges
alors c'est la tueuse elle m'a tuer deux
chats et un teckel alors on m'a dit vous
l'appliquez faux nom alors moi j non
parce que la preuve n'est pas
responsable c'est pas mais elle est
quand elle doit notre chien elle devient
folle elle est très jalouse elle ne
voulait qu'on aime qu elle toute seule
ma fille mais les gens diraient que les
gens avec les enfants avec les grandes
personnes elle est très affectueuse très
gentille alors j'ai obligé de la met au
chenil
ce qui me fait de la peine parce qu'elle
est enfermée quand même la nuit on le
laisse se promenait va se promener à va
traîner
il m'a tarn depuis on a new show mais
les communautés et la carte bien
arranger tout ça mais c'est terry ne
peut pas la laisser avec les autres un
kebab aide à vivre du nom j'en trouve
rien les quatre premières
ce à quoi elle a été levée à paris comme
une princesse elle a été avec moi elle
restait tout avec moi et puis c'est très
heureuse très gentil un peu indépendante
mystérieuse hautaine élégante et où pelé
dernière j'étais avec des enfants et des
amis à ischia en italie et nous avions
tous les jours sur la plage et déjeuner
dans un petit restaurant on était là
comme on familia pas s'occuper beaucoup
de nous et il y avait plein de charme et
le patron du restaurant pour nous faire
plaisir surtout pour faire plaisir aux
enfants comme ils disent et kesha la
balle l'été étaient bien nourris but
l'hiver il est hué basket à métro il
nous a fait cadeau d'une petite chatte
qui est mademoiselle là que vous voyez
et qui s'appelle mardi du nom de
l'endroit nous étions à mardi j'ai lu
tout petit petit petit tout petit un
très affectueuse à la passe et a été
élevée au biberon tout ça a été très
gentil et a été très surprise car à
quand elle a vu qu'elle avait une petite
cousine italienne
elles s'entendent bien sont toutes les
deux elles jouent ensemble
la leçon un peu pétrifié par la
télévision on dirait de speakerine qui
n'ont pas de texte à il va être enfin en
gros plan regardez le mais s'il ya eu
six enfants
e
ça